sherry's off today so your most accurate
weather now forecast begins with
with this great view looking a little
bit to the west and the southwest
obviously got the lights of the luxor
dancing around and the palms there
are still kind of unoccupied it is warm
even as we speak
made 91 for the highs both saturday and
sunday saturdays tied the record
yesterday's did not we'll talk more
about that let's talk about right now
a little bit of cloud cover is beginning
to clear out so we think the temperature
is going to start dropping but we're at
70 right now officially not quite that
warm in some neighborhoods we'll talk
more about that just a little breeze out
of the west southwest at five
but that is going to change we're
talking about very windy conditions
later this afternoon and tonight no wind
advisories for clark county
the only one that we have in our area is
for san bernardino county
there's the cloud cover already on its
way out so the wind will be rolling in
during the day today let's put your day
planner up here
still going to be 70 by 8 a.m should be
the low 80s and sunny at noon
but the winds picking up by three to 20
miles an hour and 88 so still very warm
with an afternoon high of 90 but by five
make that by 6 p.m
so the wind still going to be gusting to
30 miles an hour
so we'll call it mostly sunny still way
above normal and very windy we'll talk
about your eight day forecast in a few
minutes